mine is really good what we're getting
ready to talk about and i forgot i
already did my talk of the table
we're still at the table my talk at the
table is
two natives of the bronx they are
concrete and late night comedy
jesus jesus nice and the kid marrow
first made a name for themselves on
their hit podcast it's called bodega
boys last year
they began dieses and merrill the first
late night talk show on showtime
which by the way is a division of viacom
cvs they offer a very funny take on news
and pop culture between
sips of adult beverages a little
libation never hurts their recent guests
include listen to this lineup
dr anthony fauci alicia keys gold medal
sprinter usain bolt democratic nominee
joe biden
his running mate kamala harris and late
night tv legend that would be david
letterman
is that actual something this is this is
uh yes this is dominican rum
mm-hmm i'm saying what pilsner you know
the most i drank on my show was
decaffeinated coffee
you asked for coffee yeah but i just
feel like a stooge
because you're how long maybe you're
sober oh oh that's right i used to be an
alcoholic thanks
thanks you know what i feel better now
now jesus and meryl share some of their
experiences in a new book it's called
god level knowledge darts life lessons
from the bronx this morning they join us
hello mr nice and mr marrow
it's good to see you guys good morning i
want to get it
good morning it's really going great i
was so excited about you coming we all
are because
you talk about dating alpha male
becoming washed i want to get into the
book right away
dating jesus you say you know it's time
to leave a relationship
when their blinking gets on your nerves
that's right when you can hear them when
you resent them for breathing
it's time to get out of there you got to
flee for your own safety
you also have a guide to the best day to
break up you said sunday and fridays are
not good days to break up why but
tuesday is
why are sundays and fridays not so good
well sunday is like you're going to ruin
that person's week because they have to
start the week on monday and they're
going to work you don't want to do that
friday you don't want to ruin their
weekend because now they're going to
just be sad for the whole weekend so you
want to get it in there
around wednesday give them time to
discover a new netflix series
drink a little and you know get away
from the pain
miro you you don't really talk much
about dating because you were happily
married to the lovely heather you've got
four kids
four gorgeous kids yes i'm out of the
game
you're out of the game but you have a
great thing where you talk about you
have the
dad don't embarrass me stare what does
that look like
oh yeah i i have to load it up just give
me one second
mission mission accomplished the finger
can we talk about being washed because
the finger feeling that i'm watching
go ahead go ahead finish yeah everybody
everybody on screen right now is washed
yeah okay being washed that's very good
tony because they said when you're out
at the club you want to go home
you need dr scholl's gel pads you want
to chad in your jordans for
a a a pair of skechers what does being
wash mean because you said it's
different than getting older
no being watched means you want to just
say as a form of
life say again say again if you're at
the soup
it's just accepting relaxation as a form
of life
you know what i mean like like as
opposed to be like yeah i want to go
party i want to go rage
you want to just relax with a glass of
you know a nice cabernet
maybe a mile back you know what i mean
and enjoy some of your favorite
programming on a nice friday night when
everybody else is out doing handstands
and twerking
you're home enjoying a nice novel this
is your
your version of washed oh if you're ever
in the supermarket and you see a new
kind of cookie or snack
and you base your whole night around
that that's the definition of wasps
okay if you see if you go to the
supermarket
if you go to the supermarket and you see
minestrone soup is on sale and you know
you're about to have a wild weekend
that's wash baby is that you tony you
said you think
well i think what brought it home for uh
for me was when miro uh said well
you you cancel your plans and you get
really excited about whatever's on
nba uh television talking about who's
got the most rebounds of all time you're
not even watching games
you're just just the chat to go yeah
taking that in all day long just yeah
just chatter
listen it's lovely i like the outdoor
shoes the alpha male
the times to cry saving private ryan
when you order
spicy popeye's chicken and they give you
cl
they give you classic when you get home
and this one i really like jesus
when a man realizes his hairline is
going and it's not the barber's fault
it's okay to cry it's sad listen that's
a moment
that's a come to god moment you look in
the mirror you have to just be honest
with yourself because listen
you're just lying to yourself and
there's no worse lie than that like
sometimes you just got to grab the blade
and free yourself you know just just
come just come home yeah
just do it just pick it man but this is
the thing about what
what your show does guys it gives people
i think
uh relief during this particular time
i've heard many people say your show is
getting me through
i'd like to know what gets you guys
through during this time because you
must be affected by it too
yeah but we definitely have a sense of
duty the fact that we have the show and
we're able to make
the fact that we're helping other people
get through this pandemic we feel
not to make light of essential workers
but we're trying to feel like an
essential worker in that
our show is letting people you know just
get away from this have a little bit of
escape two times a week and that's what
keeps us going and trying to make the
show as funny as possible
for you meryl what gets you through
uh like jesus said being the essential
workers essential worker
you know the the trained operator the
cashier at the supermarket
everybody who you kind of like take for
granted on a regular basis
but now in in these times you realize
like wow i cannot survive without this
person so
i thought you guys at home and they're
tired
yeah i thought you guys were going to
say a good therapist
i thought both of you guys were going to
say that oh yeah hey listen
incredible twice a week listen
i get it all off my chest in there you
know what i mean double sessions
you know i mean we go hard you know
listen i go trip
i'm going through triple heart got the
calm app i got yoga and shout out to dr
mike my therapist you know you need
everything you can to just
get through these wild times nowadays i
think it's good you all talk about that
at the end of your show you ask every
illustrious guest i love that you called
them illustrious guests
what is your bodega sign miro you go
first what is your
bodega sign dieses what is yours
okay every time we're on national
television
uh my bodega sign is this heather
adrian avery amari azalea
i love you guys
all right happy hispanic heritage
what is yours all right my bodega sign
is shout out to the bronx and ma look i
am on cbs this morning
at 8 a.m and i did not commit a crime
you did not come in
continued success to you both show time
sunday nights and thursday nights i
watch you every day every week thank you
both dick
thank you so much ice cream everybody
and those are his real
sneakers those are your real sneakers
behind you too he's got a whole speaker
with the whole passage in the book about
how much there's a whole thing about
sneakers
all right the name of the sneakers hold
on the name of the book is
the name of the book god level knowledge
darts life lessons from the bronx
there you go it's on sale today whether
you wherever you like to buy your books
and
you can watch their show decent meryl
sunday and thursday nights on showtime